yeah
hey what's up guys I don't even know
what's going on for tonight mobile we
got in early so we're gonna check it out
I'm not even gonna bother here you go
but we're in we're doing it we're I
can't say it's not mobile look at all
the stuff that's on the screen I can
also have him have been like a hobo
Napoleone hood but yeah we got in he
just basically pickaxe the guy that
couldn't aim and I know what that
feelings like yes I laid one game and
it's not easy to aim do I study that
it's the Wild West out here right now
playing on the phone everyone's
everyone's trying to make a thing work
yeah it's like look you guys because
you're the Internet but I [ __ ] you not
it's not it's it ain't easy know in some
ways using the the melee was probably oh
no come on yeah here we go see no we got
another kill this is perfect this is a
be best platform for no worse platform
for this game oh I'll jump in and learn
because we just yeah I had to jump into
one earlier just kind of like guys not
doing a coke giveaway someone asked
unfortunately we don't have any to give
away sorry about that
what's up Elena Escobar michael ditzler
Niska deep looking good looking good so
you can see in the kind of top right
corner says Phil with the same platform
play against him same platform it is a
work-in-progress Bega beta can't talk
today beta and for now
there's no cosplay but yeah we're
playing it it's on a phone yeah trying
to still trying to take it all in once
you practice you're aiming now because
that would be a thing and jump shooting
try jump shooting this is a shoot so to
jump shoot there is like like a giant
that you see on the far right I have two
fingers to work with you have to shoot
oh yeah yeah the old the old like
spider-man it did I actually kill a guy
no you can't kill anyone
he's left then and then building is kind
of awkward I don't even I don't know man
I feel like I don't even want to build
but I kind of wish we had a controller
just to kind of like it really would be
though is a gym thing I don't know if
you're watching the screen where whoever
that's watching the stream out there if
we have a iOS compatible controller I
like to go grab that upgrade our stream
so yeah we're on gamespot twitch
periscope youtube what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in to what we hope to
be as a fun time here as we play this
game on them hot mobile hot mobiles
we'll keep switching on and off yeah
just so that I feel the pain that Ben's
going through which is I don't even know
what's the best gun here that the burst
rifle might actually be decent because
some guy got me real bad this is the
thing right now top tier meta I'm gonna
call it within the first 20 minutes of
the the beta being up on the phone the
meta is pickaxe because it doesn't run
out of ammo and you can kind of just go
with it yeah lol with some zero says you
can't aim while shooting you know yes
but when you're using yours on a phone
dream it don't feel that great to be
honest unless hey maybe your mobile god
guys gonna say if you're if you play
shooting games on your mobile phone
first of all what the heck are you doing
second of all this is perfect for you
because you're you're ready for it until
they cross platform and then it's
probably yeah keep the same platform as
an option maybe things fair I feel like
they're gonna have to because if I'm
playing this against a PC person I'm
just gonna get frustrated not installed
we are technically you know playing
against people that have it it's filled
right now right yeah I mean unless for
some reason you know I didn't see anyone
else coming in there the one person
covered up by the microphone we're gonna
go in my dad it's okay I will say to the
interesting thing as Ben had pointed out
that I didn't notice oh yeah
yeah tactical little burst here is that
you I don't know if you guys can see it
but there's a slight outline that was
not what I want is that good
the okay okay like sound indicators on
the on the screen I guess in case you
don't happen to have it even has a chest
in it yeah it tells you everything there
we go oh I want to watch people use the
bomb jumps with how no see it's aiming
at the ground right and then run past it
okay I mean that's that's kind of it I'm
not very accurate but so what you want
to do is like as you're running drop it
on the ground oh come on
he's also struggling work with me here
potato given that potato him come on my
dude come on down there come on down see
you come on dude you're you only have
one bullet though oh I should probably
god I you have the full stop to like you
thought you could outsmart me not today
okay so you wanna click on the web me
that yeah I don't want that anymore I'm
not actually it's doing me pretty pretty
well here I need to yeah okay drink this
first that was a mistake that that guy
made by not drinking those you should
keep the shields though yeah so good oh
yeah you wanna get out no stop it take
me back no Andrew yeah we're on iPhone
right now god
okay swap that out no you don't have to
keep that if you don't want to you you
know I don't that to you alright this is
some bandages let's check out the rest
of these we're currently on a phone I'm
actually I'll show will hold it up later
just so you guys I mean like it's very
good after this that we're playing on
mobile if you can't tell but you know
come on you can clearly pre-prepared
video that we put buttons over and crank
the PC down yeah and we yell as like we
struggle right
every damn day it's a struggle uh
there's nothing left in here this is
fine okay we gotta go were you gonna
head to you I'm just gonna open up the
map yep it's all intuitive touch
touchscreen you know what's gonna happen
right we're all gonna start playing this
on phone no well I reload if you can
because that's making more sales oh no
you just hit the gun again
dude be creamer says if the bursts do
the burst is so good wash all the
proteins man there is gonna be if we
didn't have enough or a lot of people
already playing this game think of how
many Cola God's right we're gonna play
fortnight on their parents phones yeah
yeah that's gonna be a big thing like a
huge yeah huge I don't think they're
gonna understand all of it but there's a
little jumpin gonna be a demographic
it'll be a thing we've got 33 people
left if we're doing Justin got to like
top 10 in his first game dang we don't
have any codes unfortunately everyone
sorry about that we we got in a little
early or I don't know if we actually got
in early some people might be getting
invites already but oh yeah that was
another weird thing I thought I was
gonna have to press a button and then I
didn't sense a chest with my
spider-sense your your little sensor
meter their sense above me fun fact if
it is above you you don't want to smash
that I've learned this the hard way and
I'm sure you know this which I don't
find awkward what the heck did I just do
that's fine this is not fine this is
fine
opposite of funny you knocked down the
ground that the chest is on you lose the
chest no I think it's about the bathroom
I think it's above the bathroom I think
you're good yeah yeah no that's all it
was all your spider sense your
you-know-what phone are you playing on
it I forget which model of iPhone this
is question much here an 8 or 10
say can't Bluetooth controllers work
with this I'm not 100% sure that's what
I wanted to find out I think they would
have many up to 75 also you should check
the circle later but I think you got
some time you got too much yeah I'm good
no one's gonna be able to walk into this
house fast enough to kill me while I'm
doing this so I just got an email saying
welcome to the for now I haven't invited
vent on iOS and the email didn't have a
code so John uh what I had in my email
was like uh like you hit a get or shoot
what was the exact it's it's a it gave
me a link that sent me to the iOS like
place or you want that shield by the way
I can't suck anymore but yeah it'd
probably be a good idea I think you
should keep it oh come on I don't think
you need a good name let's be real here
so it was a link to the iOS like App
Store right yeah and then it was like
click this to get the thing and then
once you get it it downloads and then
you log in with your epic account yeah
basically just to watch out the shot
he's right there baby look at this
crouched egg oh it's not helping it
doesn't do anything for you get God this
hold on it's going to take like five
minutes too late yet definitely
definitely more shots we can use
controller I wanted to see if someone
out there could could potentially grab a
controller if we have anything that's
iOS compatible I kind of just rushed to
get this stream up yeah I thought you
were talking about tomorrow no I meant I
was like I'm shooting right this minute
here we are we got a monster hunter
tomorrow we do what we're gonna do yet
because deviljho is not till next week
yeah I'm gonna embarrass myself trying
to use a charged way probably I can
embarrass myself with like a great sword
or something sounds like a plan I don't
know later the the options thing is in
the very top right corner I like how it
shows you how much battery oh yeah
that's really nice because I know when I
play fortnight really late into the
night I definitely don't think about my
battery I'm not a lolly I'm not sure if
you can use Google Play cards to buy be
bucks I have or Apple even Apple Store
iTunes when you have no idea I don't
even know if the store is up in this yet
grammar police clearly doesn't huge fan
of the fortnight but that's that's on
you I used to think that I wasn't gonna
get into fortnight and the more I watch
it the more I find it I don't know if
it's just because the actions feels more
constant and there's a lot more going on
that I just I don't know I I think I
actually like the game for your sheet
how quick it is
yeah you just hop back into another game
right yeah yeah yeah I like both the
Battle Royale games are going on right
now I'm not
I don't like hate either one in
particular though it is kind of lame
that like play unknowns put theirs out
and it started to do so well that epics
like hmm let's just take that and then
they did it another players there's true
there's different differences for sure
that aren't in that game that oh is that
a controller just pair it man yeah just
you you rub it up against it until it
connects but then that antenna okay wait
hold on it stored that's well we do that
for your switch turn lure you get to
place the controller this is like a hack
right here this is a that's a phone grip
this is gonna be this is how we're gonna
destroy people right here so oh man
that's not even fair
like no one's died yet the circles
closing in Mad Max uh we haven't
actually tried on our mobile service we
are just on our company Wi-Fi right now
what's it what do you say the circle is
really far let's say so we've gone on
and maybe like five people have died
since last time I was PA well what do
you expect
I you know come on yeah you drink that
and then pick those those suckers back
up oh this is great dude I'm feeling I'm
feeling a win here a victory Royale
this is a iOS this is a hot fortnight
iOS it's on a phone that we're gonna try
to pair to this Xbox one controller and
if we can do that man we're gonna be
sitting pretty I'm gonna try to walk
into this
thing it's ammo I'm on the gun I already
have yeah but isn't it a better version
of it I'm just gonna burst you know
that's why I got somebody's more eats
more ammo here yeah more ammo I can
shoot down range the better at this can
I work on an iPod 6 gen I don't know no
Walters again we pretty much downloaded
it on a few phones Oh actually you know
what I think Randy was on iPhone 6 maybe
Plus and it looked really good on his
too so I would have imagined that it'd
be fine maybe that's a test in itself hi
here's all the iOS every phone Mart
where why it works on you know answering
my questions no problem keep them coming
guys I'll if we have answers we will try
to send them to you Carl Bret but but
baedeker's I guess I don't see an
Annapolis or I think that you actually
have to get the invite email from epic
and then that email at least for us had
a link that then brought us to like an
like an Apple Store situation where we
could actually download it so uh-huh Oh
who's this oh he heard you because so
far well he probably saw the little
footsteps on the middle of the
controller step out my dude I like how
nobody's building naw dude that's that's
too much at this point
oh he got he's got grenades oh that's
fine that's fine if he wants to keep
doing that I'm just gonna roll up with a
shotgun year whatever no you don't know
we got a hundred shield
that autumn is very very generous yikes
might swap this out for this though
that's fine you should we call it up
shield up yeah if you can safely kind of
smart alike check and see build a house
that's all right paranoia see where is
the opposite of everything I want the
building oh you're in the circle perfect
just like I planned here we go let's
build let's build a home one there yep
yep yep here goes is exactly what I
imagined building the house and at
fortnight we're building a maze here we
go someone's found me that's fine that's
good now you have leverage now you have
you have the high ground I know this
guy's see you where are you so good but
he's to your left as the center yeah
yeah I might just run out and okay you
do yeah see behind the tree definitely
to your left somewhere I think yeah that
way oh well you know he can stay on top
of the hill that's okay
it's not behind the tree oh he is
actually hitting me it's gonna try to
serpentine I zigzag a bit interesting
there's eight left we have four kills
come on the real question is can you
dance I don't know
show them that you got the know Jeff
Araya you know what that's fine that's
I'm okay with that's as I don't think
we're gonna top that I feel like we
might it's very possible but yeah you
know I'm Way out of my depth I've never
had device tried to take an adventure in
finding out how things work okay I know
there's no controller thing here I is
there like within the phone itself
should we like switch the thing over to
the camera so we can like not not show
Justin's like phone things while we
while we venture around I think we might
have to do it in the actual phone
settings properly everything
settings Bluetooth is on so how do i how
does one do you have to just hit the
sync button let's see my device is other
devices find this Xbox buying this
controller please can buttons be
remapped this is the experimental part
where we tour and all the buttons yes
don't go into the gallery upload all the
pictures of Facebook yoyo lower we don't
have any codes unfortunately connect
Dual Shock bluetooth
I'm trying to connect an xbox oh oh I
just turned off this controller so when
you turn it on and then hit the button
at the top to sync it if you can touch
it oh here let me let me see oh I can
handle the controller and then I'll go
back into the game
yeah yes yeah is are we doing it is it
going it's syncing you you think they'd
let a Microsoft controller Linda I don't
you got 1.7 periscope live viewers hi
hello I like it famous fam I hope so
we not Drake famous but you know not not
quite you know this might not pair with
it I don't I don't think we can pair now
leave me alone Siri take two just ask
Siri to link in an Xbox controller I
just want his desktop if people are
watching you sent us this controller how
do how do I do how do I get back does
that work I think oh yeah go it's
probably on the front front page help me
my dude here what Xbox controller
doesn't connect to an iPhone good to
know we figure they don't allow
connecting two controllers that's not
true because I think there's definitely
some there's definitely some iOS
controllers out there we solved it what
we saw getting back it's okay because
now I get to watch you try to figure out
how to play this on the cellular phone
oh yeah let's check out the store season
pass is still there the battle challenge
is cool loadouts oh yeah it's all up
profile and no offers available for VBox
oh you can't buy VBox but you can look
at stuff in the store yeah somebody out
there wanna want to tell me what's up
that'd be great
just play the effing game you got it in
stock we're on it then when I play
you're gonna be like get better and it's
like man why why can't you do all the
kills broke to UK man she's I like that
he's like alive updates from from she Oh
B hunt says that epic says it won't have
controller support flat-out what also
what's up behind I miss you that was the
whole point
yeah we thought we were slick it streams
over I canceled canceled but who was
controller Stephano we'll never know
because we can't connect it
unfortunately I really wish we could
just give everyone who wants a code a
code you know I don't even think would
they be able to give out codes like two
or three gigs cuz we actually had to we
had to clear out space on the cuz I
installed it on our thing that we used
for Instagram the iPad that we have and
I had we had to clear stuff out and I
was like oh how big is this actually and
I think it was two or three gigs dongle
huh this dongle right here that's a good
see look I just want you to know that
we're not there you go I was we didn't
put those icons on there but it's all
theirs
dongle is making it real hard mics are
not the same level please pick sec I
mean we all we all talk different levels
too if I do this and I start getting
real loud and talk real loud I'm gonna
fire start peaking but hopefully that's
better for you
yeah cuz you you know that it's gonna
get real real intense here in this game
oh yeah I'm sure she P I'm gonna start
yelling
Bob Jones Bobby Jones I'll try it
wait oh oh we should just have the the
tech people bring in every controller
yeah everything we have
I where we going where we got so you can
kind of this is stupid stick to consoles
you can't take your Xbox one on public
transport
yeah man can't be you can't be that if
you ever wanted to play and I think our
phone is actually dying ton of - oh we
might have to swap swap phones is
machine is gonna end when this ends
Randy we need your phone we need a phone
we need another phone that's really
weird that that doesn't charge it this
is just a video out man yeah it's got
visual cues for sound which is kind of
rad
so if you're playing for instance on
public transportation on your way to
work in the morning I regret ever to
have headphones in dude you're fine just
I have been around this is so much
better when you're watching someone else
do I don't want to play got more
controllers oh no exact are they do they
work though oh thank you we have so many
gotcha gotcha
literally hint I saw like an oh shoot I
just want to open the door my but you do
a live unboxing here so we have a super
gamepad is this is this just a joke no
this isn't a joke this is this is
fortnight on mobile dude I'm not work
yes that you have to touch with your
finger
I am 300 firmly firmly touch it with
firmly yes okay there's a chest them so
I'm gonna open this controller up and
we're gonna see if it pairs up and it'll
be a good time for everyone nice
packaging I like it it's very clean you
can't take your xbox one on public
transport is that a challenge
Stefan oh if you did it I'll be very
impressed and I'd also like to shake
your hand because whenever I think of
public transport I think of the public
transport out here in San Francisco and
I don't know if you'd want to bring an
Xbox onto there alright so what do we
got here
let's take a look we got some warnings a
cool little plastic thing that a troll
box Oh God
now dude none of this is troll this is
for real dude I I can't wait till you
have to play again oh it's just dongle
on the the
morning it's like every time dongle
comes up just for Shiva yeah
got a cool little super gamepad manual
so we can find a way around all the
buttons and it's actually just get in
here I'm wondering how long I can take
this for this is oh look at that do you
see that that was the next level what
are you what are your tactics stay what
are you doing oh no if I hit that is it
like right above me I think yeah I think
it is right above me okay so we've got
the controller here it's very light it's
got a nice Super Nintendo theme to it
it's got a turbo button
don't let revolver ocelot know about
that he'll call you out yeah we can we
can try pairing this up and see what
it'll do at some point oh no do did you
destroy it yes oh my goodness I hit it
one too many times oh this this actually
plugs into the the old this for like a
Wii what are you even looking at right
yes for the we're the Wii what is this
isn't Jimmy did we get got maybe unless
unless it's like a a Wii Wii U Bluetooth
controller hope though now it's a switch
port so that's actually interesting
thing sheepy because if they're putting
it on mobile the like from what I hear
I'm not very technical the architecture
for the switch is basically a mobile
platform and yeah you put that up on
your Nintendo switch can have a lot of
good good times
sup Josh Shaw how you doing what up J
Shaw you came for that hot 4:9 mobile
huh
did your you're rocking this right now
like yes dad I'm roll I'm real proud of
you
why I haven't killed anyone you're
killing these houses though
Big Willie Android not yet hopefully
soon because then I can actually try it
on my phone oh is it just in here this
oh my god
you found it congratulations you've won
do fortnight's so hot right now beyond
hot the hottest the hottest I don't
think this is Bluetooth I don't know why
we guy got
yeah are we gone oh it's also for the
NES classic edition god I don't look 80s
guys oh just get out of here it's time
for that I'll leave it out and we can
look at it I guess I don't know man this
is this is this is a an experience to
say the least can bring your laptop on
transport you know what actually boss
you got me with that you can definitely
try giving it a go on a lap so you won't
always have Wi-Fi it's gonna say the
connection might be a little spotty and
you might drop out but you could
probably play into part of a game that
might work not a full thing though all
right we got 36 alive uh
I have not seen anyone people asking if
it's got cross plate I don't think cross
play is enabled on this right now at
least in the little like beta text it
says same platform for everything but
close this up still have an invite I you
know it might happen soon oh no Wi-Fi
tethering
I think everyone's got answers you know
what everyone's got answers hey I can't
do it like I said man this is this is
gonna fill the the child the kidney
although this thing seems to be eating
up battery pretty Yeah right if anyone
is watching for real though I don't know
maybe like like a charger or a different
phone no no we can't charge we'll have
to have a different phone we should
chest it out another phone Randy we need
your eye iPhone 6 we could try playing
it on the watching a stream oh yeah iPad
2 we could try it all but the resolution
was weird the resolution is real weird
but I guess we could test multiple
platforms you know for the side which
I've had was the one that we tried it on
that had the [ __ ] resolution it's the
one we use for posting to Instagram okay
well that that doesn't tell me which one
it is but thanks I can't I don't know I
don't I don't know all these yours this
is hurting my eyes
is that a person dude are you about to
get your murder on I don't know I can't
tell everything looks oh that is a
person you got this
keep giving them that strafe and they
won't be able to do anything yeah there
it is
shield man shields pay dividends Oh
supposed to rain is it that's what the
iPads telling me just gonna open this up
again so that we gotta crouch this is
what they do they crouch to do that oh
yeah yeah and you gotta you know wiggle
back and forth to got to get your wiggle
on are you able to play with mobile data
I assume so but we we haven't tried it
so I don't know 100%
apparently there's a chest in the
container around here someone's saying
or maybe that was a while back yes this
is the the problem with dealing with
live streams you know I can't I can't
right now I'm I'm just doing my darndest
to stay alive I'm happy we got a kill
that's already a win in my book given
given what we're working with here Oh
was that soin shooting could seriously
resurrect the PS vita dude that's the
best dream I feel bad about the Vita
every day and I wish that they found a
way to make it work can I plan your dude
if you could play on your Nokia that's
for snake all right that snake and snake
alone
snakes belong in Alaska and snake yeah
this is really even 80s on yours yeah I
I don't think you're supposed to play it
on this is what it is on that the
version you have so there is limitations
and right yeah we'll find out if we ever
have to plug it in to play it how to get
a code I think you just get invited it's
their choosing stuff sending it out to
people it's not a code either so like we
can't we can't let give away a thing I
just gave up my position it's all all in
the link that they sent in an email
can't wait for it to be your turn come
on guys shoot a lot of people now do we
I'm looking so there
I wish that we control the flow of
people but we can we can go to tilted
and blue next time yeah that's fair
those are I kind of wish that that that
pickaxe kill ya was real good it's
really difficult to use the controls
with fortnight mobile it's not optimum I
would say it's doable I think that if
for some reason you haven't played
fortnight it might feel less weird but
after playing I play on PC you play on
console after playing and spending so
much time on those platforms it's very
hard to kind of like adjust to this and
I don't play too many mobile shooters
yeah personally so it's definitely a
little weird for me I mainly play like
games like hearthstone
puzzle fighter things that things that
kind of lend themselves well to the
mobile platform yes those are correct
when is fortnight coming to the Gameboy
Color
not soon enough well it's not easy to
hit these blue circles right now yeah
that's bad no it's your you can't react
to that stuff that's there's too much
going on thanks man you're so you're so
kind
it's these are the the true facts okay
this knows you you're two straight A's
you can't confirm you can't aim very
well in fortnight on mobile my thumb is
not very good where's the shoot button
there's an auto fire so when you shoot
it's you kind of just tap like the right
side of the screen any part that isn't a
button come on
which is kind of weird oh shoot dude you
got it close it up it's murder o'clock
is he/she not getting in here is he
rubbing against the outside and then
technically I could edit this thing but
your shotgun that's pretty alright yeah
there you go
I dare you this is real right Panda I
don't even I can't oh oh wow this guy
built above me okay this guy's pretty
good it's a fortnight pro that guy's
pretty good
good job Joe Giovanni that's how you
should play it I couldn't build fast
enough I mean he's been around the block
spaceman like I don't know it felt weird
there for me I was trying to edit the
the like the my house yeah it didn't
work there you go
you sure you don't want to do another
one just so like I and I did a couple
all right fine uh cuz you want you got
to get in there yah tight you gotta warm
up you got to get into it get into the
flow yeah okay what uh I think he said
that so that he didn't have to play
another game uh I would too though yes I
feel like like two game to game switch
office is a good way to do it no no no
no this is the thing right now
I literally just swiped no I notice a
photo fortnight on mobile is uh can you
help me out I think I think this is the
this is the cancel button and this is
the watch it has a password and this is
uh-huh thank you boy did it crack the
code how is yours working ours is
working it's working
it's controller as of right now now we
can try to try to link up this thing
they don't doesn't have batteries there
are no batteries included we can't even
yeah man I got I can't believe this
just do something for tonight on the on
your God should just do a gallery top
top don't ten platforms for tonight
hasn't come to yet
yeah Mad Max it seems like they're
linked together so if you uh if you uh
if you log in it'll let you do your
foreign I think it says your your PC
account your ps4 account and your phone
account can all be linked box is coming
let me post this little the link to the
download please do you actually Emily
that's interesting
Gatling ghosts if you signed up you may
or may not have gotten an email getting
in so I didn't have to we didn't do any
new accounts for the game we just logged
in with our epic yeah so yeah mine keeps
crashing it's a bit so beta crashes are
inevitable they could definitely happen
how you get the app we got a link from
oh that's a person who's playing on
PlayStation and then that guy wrecked me
dude it's fine you know it's if I were
to ever play for tonight I don't know if
this would be the first place I'd run to
I would definitely wait til I got home
and boot up my computer or my ps4 or my
ex keeps crashing what platform or what
a phone are you on I guess or iOS device
could you actually install it on the
Apple watch could you and you just kind
of like play it with two fingers kind of
yeah we're gonna go to tilted and do it
dude jump in it's also the quickest way
to end your turn
don't don't don't tell him don't do it
you need to know that you didn't need to
know that Ben Oh batteries that's not
gonna help I'm just gonna unroll here
the controller unless somebody knows
something we don't like the controller
there's no setting in the app that
allows us to I'm not giving up because
it means I can play with the controller
if I get it to work sorry
you know we should a Ritchie Ritchie
who's giving us all this stuff you know
we should do get Randy's iPhone 6 in
case this thing runs out of battery also
just to see what that looks like and how
that runs because people are asking
about iPhone 6 thank you
this is definitely a controller that now
has batteries inside of it okay
so we're gonna try to sync it again I
mean we could we could try and give it a
go oh you didn't see me oh good I can
finally put them in all someone's coming
seals footsteps moving real quick where
do you put the coat so it's not a code
it's if anyone's giving you a code
that's a that's a lie it's a link to Oh
God
Jew digger one circles around him yes Oh
see them easy GG easy no we I had a
shield that's why nice oh here we go
here we go again
oh no you got this three oh he didn't
even have to do anything he just shot in
the dam you know I'm clean again okay do
it dude I am into this salty it's good
it's good whack dude I only had to do is
aim into the the damn room I would have
loved to have done that I also wanted
the shotgun not that stupid triple thing
Randy's on the way boys thank you
awesome
got my avatar now Oh killing it okay you
need an external battery old man Roman
no I don't think that's the problem I
don't even know if we can connect the
two hello cool oh nice I want you to
play with me okay wait can't we well we
can clucking squad okay I just I hear
you you gonna die yeah and then all I'll
jump in with you we can do a squad what
other people wale this is exact this is
how I would work in real in the real
world you come up to your friend and be
like aeo fortnight's squad and they'd be
like hell yeah dude I'm down oh I can
practice building I like how there's a
giant show help button that's what I
need more than anything
switch downloaded the aperture on a
waiting list
you mean if you mean like a waiting list
to log in that's just cuz there's a
queue there's so there was a queue when
I tried to log in it's probably still a
queue I'm guessing since everyone's
getting their their stuff all together
for it sure two x n-- astronaut killed
you that's that's the maximum astronaut
you can be except for the no that is the
maximum astronaut how you get this game
we got sent a an access code and then we
we downloaded it
build roofs everywhere and build it put
roofs on the ground roofs
Ruff's playing fortnight on ps4 come on
please do you're playing in a better
place I don't know what I don't don't
know what to tell you other than just it
I mean like I said unless you're really
into like you just have to play
fortnight all the time I think we're on
an AIDS and you know I don't think this
is a 10 right I'm not I'm not an apple
guy I'm not I'm not either we probably
should have brought in an apple person
just to be like ah I'll field all your
Apple questions that's what what that's
what people care about the Apple
question exactly it's real important
we're going to tilt it again it's a good
call because we're gonna we're gonna try
out squats after that and I'm curious if
you think that so I know Randy's got an
iPhone 6 so whatever I want is like
newer than yours
do you I want to know if you well one
you have less real estate because it's a
smaller you have a smaller phone yeah
well we'll find out I I'm really not
looking forward to trying to play on the
the iPad because I'm gonna try it later
even if it's not on stream cuz that that
looks rough I guarantee it's gonna be
rough when I try to play is this
half-life 3 hunter if you want it to be
it can be anything you'd like it to be
oh no oh gosh shotgun mine is crashing
what do I do it might just be like
server stuff things going crazy through
multiple chests in here it's a beta so
there might just be some weird version
issues with whatever phone you've got
there are a lot of things that could be
influencing it's crashing or knots
that town looks like Jimmy Neutron it's
my favorite kind of town
apple is important when a day keeps the
doctor away
Stefano very true that's what I meant to
do you know ooh
heard a shot there that's not good real
dangerous what I Oh s devices were both
playing on phones that much I know I
think this one is a six Oh
calculated all according to plan dead
from the first couple of shots he's had
that uh that railing in his way he is a
top tier protecting afk yeah I think
that I think this is an iPhone 6 that I
have right now that I'm about to play on
but you're watching a tape player rocket
launcher dude there's a chug chug thing
or not I checked a big shield no no it's
not a slurp juice
sorry Jenga Slurpees o tang IV slurping
I missed the slurp juice I'm even dare
to use rockets it sounds like a hey are
we doing it yeah cuz the six live stream
I don't know if if we can find the time
for it I'd be down we did one a little
while ago but I'd like to come back you
ready for this terrible idea
no dude this is the best idea you're in
a small enclosed space with a rocket
launcher and then I'm gonna like miss
dude I'm so scared you can't click on
the box cuz it's gonna yeah they're
scared that was the idea I got you now
what could go wrong here I think it'd be
faster on an iPhone act 8 or X probably
I mean iPhone 6 works yes I Randy said
this was a 6 right yeah I believe so
yeah so we got it running on a 6 right
here
no getting some cool cool notifications
yeah I feel like that's the biggest
downside to playing on the phone let's
be honest so I think this phone is a
little bit smaller than that well
footsteps I feel really big dumb meaty
grabbers like I can't where are you at
there just shoot you in there open up I
think there's someone on the roof oh you
fell down
this is it this is the moment you know
that the medkit here we go here we go
yeah took out the mack daddy no no no no
so the emails come out yet we got ours a
little while ago I think I think they're
going out then should be a thing if you
signed up keep-keep Europe eyes peeled
where do you check your kills at the the
upper left Renner Internet yep with the
skull so you've got the time remaining
until the circle closes how many people
are left and then how many people Eve
killed confirm works on 6c I got you my
dude it's all all here in my hand dude
treasure box says or something here but
my treasure sense is there tingling but
I'm not finding the box oh wait there it
is I see it am I gonna meet Lee am I
gonna be so I think it's I think it's
off to the side you're good down below
so you know you're coming from the top
so you can't mess up there you go you
just kind of break that down break it
down what are you Dante what is that
Lucy oMG it's been a while I'm excited
to get back into overwatch nope didn't
mean to do that do you feel the controls
are intuitive enough or difficult to
manage so there's a level of Intuit II
to them like they make sense where I was
like oh how do I expand the map and I
clicked on the map and it made it bigger
but there's also something to be said
about trying to aim with your thumb on a
touchscreen that just doesn't like
register with my mind so I'm I'm having
kind of a weird time with it but I could
see some people kind of being into it
yeah it kind of works exactly how do you
think it works someone tried on the
iPhone 7 I haven't Oh slurp juice heck
yeah that's the gym chest in the family
upstairs my crashes when I open it again
it's it's a beta guys so there there
might be some issues going on a lot of
people are downloading and getting in
server disconnections all sorts of
things keep trying you'll probably be
able to make it in keep your eye on
their Twitter they'll probably give you
updates on what's going on and
no the real treasure chests was the
friends we made along the way because
this one doesn't exist you know I I mean
I don't see it downstairs was I thought
it was a sniper rifle for a second so
this will eventually connect to the
other versions of the game I don't think
it does right now why did the ammo dang
try it try breaking the floor I don't
know if that's a good swap how dare you
I mean I'm not gonna question you I'm
not gonna tell you what to do that's
definitely a ground floor I really don't
think this chest exists also guys don't
pay for codes cuz it's not a code I'm
trying to save you
also just ban the Savior just go
download it for free or play it on your
computer that's you please hello I don't
think I've ever like I've ever been in
the the storm oh that would be bad I got
real lucky someone already made some
steps for you though there you go
there's a downstairs what's you see
anyone chat oh the water looks pretty
good i how how how did i just shoot when
i had the damn build out i you know
you're breaking new grounds new meta is
evolving everyday you just find out all
those really cool secrets we're beta
testing yeah we are we beta now we are
definitely better now
I have it on the iPhone but when I load
it says get on the waiting list so maybe
it's a queue of people to get in servers
are full it might be a server queue or
it could be that invite links are unique
oh so I'm trying to use other people's
so if if it's telling you to wait in the
list it's probably just being like hey
man this has already been used you can't
do this maybe I'm just guessing cuz we
were able to get in so I don't know
exactly but yeah we've had some people
say that that not a person that's person
because a thing popped up that's a rock
I think no it's a lag that ah it's a
person who's disconnected great okay
just keep shooting them just you think
so a little bit I'm about the number of
shots that you think would kill someone
all right I'd probably [ __ ] off Matt's
they're in for a rude awakening kill
they really kills me uh yeah
what so that was a good round of
fortnight Battle Royale
that you just played it was actually you
that was disconnected the whole time
maybe that's why you couldn't find the
chest - now do you bet yeah we're just
gonna swap it over like I was gonna play
here you know oh we're plugging in that
way well you know mines now and stuck in
loading well we might as well get one
that we know is on tonight yeah there we
go it definitely should be fine don't
worry I'll bring back again so this is
now gonna be here in a second hopefully
this will be iPhone 6 if there's any
time no we're just hot swapping phones
everywhere there we go it looks slightly
worse yeah yeah a little a little a
little more rough but they do have
squads up I don't know are you still
loading her yeah
can I kill it can I kill the app I think
maybe you all you want me to see if you
can get any want to mess around with it
I can no I got this nut I'm jumping I'm
jumping in I'm going in
not here yeah I can I can try to figure
it out if you want me to are you got it
no what if the server's just went down I
don't know we're loading into this one I
trust everyone outside think that was an
iPhone 8 is what Justins is I'm now
playing on an iPhone 6 assuming it works
I don't know we'll see oh there it was I
held down on the button hard enough it
told me to share fortnight
here we go problem occurred oh this
isn't that good I'm getting slack
messages surprise oh yeah hold on let me
sneeze notifications Oh where's that
right right there hi Randy for the next
hour an hour there we go we had to do it
all so this one's good to go again if I
yep just yep we're hot swapping here you
want me to pull the thing out er no no
no watch yours okay fine
give it back to me yeah because we know
that ones at least goodish well we
didn't we want to show them the iPhone 6
oops it's gonna take a second it's gonna
say no signal but it's gonna come back
it'll be there trust us I should go back
to camera nope and of course as it go
back to camera there no there goes all
right I wonder if I can just back out of
this oh do you want me okay I'm gonna
wait yeah let's let's actually try to do
this here leave managed mode squad but
then there's this score doesn't let us
we have to front a quest each other
probably
what's Justin hey wall it's dinging
yours what's yours
turtle stack hello oh there's a there's
a moon mode you know what too
complicated I think we're all right now
but we'll hit up I just anyone
oh okay I I don't think anyone is
particularly good at this this this
version did that work yeah yeah we're
friends no no I'm party we're doing it
okay so we're we're doing it now double
trouble here we go
I do we bug hit ready so we can't yeah
we both have to hit I'm gonna hit this
Phil hit ready so we're gonna fill our
squad with randoms if anyone is actually
playing this crazy charity to for
trouble here we go make it double I'm so
ready to fumble around with this this
phone is very small mmm that's right
I mean I'm I feel like to get the full
experience I have to at least try a game
with a smaller phone so you have all
perspectives exactly I like to gather
perspectives that's why I think that's
140 I think it's going on yeah yeah
check that that would have stopped
recording trying to get some some some
sweet footage
some sick footage oh did it look a lot
different for you guys probably did huh
call it you eyes like this bone forces
that haha that guys having a real fun
time floating in the air
alright where are we going then that's a
good question you want to just drop into
the towers again cuz it just gets action
right yeah all right we got who do we
got here we got trill fil-a Oh Chris I
like this troll chill fills my uh my
alter-ego
Lizzy yeah damn this one looks a lot
better oh thanks okay good to know yeah
this one nah I got some sweet drift
physics going on I don't know joyeux the
ceiran says
I think is trying to milk this game too
much I don't think so either way I look
at it is like you want to be able to put
your game on as many platforms as
possible and it's free yeah so it's like
it's your choice if you want to play it
or not and you don't have to buy any of
the custom stuff or the skins so I don't
I don't know I mean if you view that as
milking sure I view it as you have you
as a consumer have options yeah I think
it's just getting it out on as many
places as you can do we ever find out if
that was able to play the other flippin
Canadian subs Oh tilted right yeah you
actually opening up them happen yeah
dude hey I hardly ever mark anything in
this game and apparently weird I forgot
who is telling me was like you want to
try to aim 1 square is when you want to
like it I don't know dude but tomato
town I usually go to tomato town so low
but it's made of towns a pretty cool
place I am gonna drop out same heading
the Tilted heading to trouble can we get
an invite when you signed up you'll
probably get one later on I feel like
they're just gonna eventually add you to
the boards yeah they're gonna try to
like stress tested or something so that
when the stress test happens that's when
you are you dropping in a specific
building are we separating oh I'm gonna
try to go for that that building with
the the weird top that you can kind of
fall into the air conditioning okay yeah
except there's there's like maybe just
melee this guy come back here come back
here double-team of Ben
mm I'm trying this phone's got some
where are you going he's going the other
way Oh sandwich there we go there we go
yeah where are your buddies where are
your buddies a real cool murder going on
right now this is called your friends
we got to get we gotta get down all
right so I think there's a chest right
below me here there is double tapping it
Medhi AR there's a pump shotgun I don't
even know how to drop a gun I mean you
just drag it up I tried that didn't work
you just want this or do you want attack
oh I just sit the tack whatever you're
good I got this I'm set this is all I
need oh person here
oh he one shot me get him while he's
shooting me I'm bait I'm the bait I'm
coming here an or or revive me survive
he revived you you're reviving me uh-uh
it doesn't show me that I'm reviving you
know yeah you're good you're good
six seconds he's coming up no he's I
thought I could I thought I could wait
it out I was wrong I was dead wrong at
okay yeah there's there so there's no
indicator when you're reviving someone
so I had no idea what time it was at
unless I was looking at your screen dang
it this phone is driving me mad it
kicked me out I think that's not good
I'm back yeah you know what seemed Aloha
I think that's how I'm coming to you
this nine seconds I'm very surprised at
how this game looks as well like for a
mobile game but it does look worse on
yours and it did look kind of funky on I
because you want to show them how bad it
can get you want to will do that Dad you
will show them all three platforms how
about that at the end we'll do it all
three and then we'll try to oh you're in
queue I'm trying to join you right now
did that work uh it says you're online
I'm gonna maybe wait to party except I
accidentally why did you ready let's do
it yeah try again at least we got that
melee killing that one guy I was pretty
good I'm into it
man I should have killed that other guy
I didn't think he was coming up so fast
and shotguns like one shot pretty much
yeah that close think the iPhone 6 will
be it I mean it's so fine I don't know
how much how many how much what kind of
games you want to play I guess yeah
J hey o P I don't know about that how do
you change the graphics that's a good
question I don't know I think it
automatically changes it depending on
what phone system I'm running other app
not app saw hardware because I didn't
see anything in the options when we
dropped in
I don't know Giovanni Sanchez while
you're 49 mobile keeps crashing we had a
couple ourselves I'm on one bar which is
fun loading takes a bit longer on this
one too
all right we got to go to tilt it again
I mean oh that guy's got the loser you
mote thank you I wanna emot-- emote on
my phone how Siri how to emote oh it's
this it's that top right that little
bubble next to your thing Oh give me
that
hmm give me that oh I don't get
first-person perspective I can't what I
can't spin what so you got to go look at
me where are you at I'm right next to
you oh yeah killing it
it only plays one of the songs that
seems like it's not the one I wanted did
you guys have a few crashes - we did
crash a once or twice yeah that was my
first crash sit I'm willing to bet it's
probably the server's I mean is day one
working progress beta like stuff like
that is bad in happen.we
how are the controls organic grunt their
their phone controls so if you can
handle phone controls you'll you'll do
well Felton yeah I'm yeah yeah what the
yeah your New York Times you're trying
to drop been real hard a lot became
notification some New York time
notification hey what if there was
something important thing you know it's
really important that I know what's
going on in the news while I play for at
night when do you want a job ouch
yeah I'm done
why don't you for the the same building
the air conditioning yeah sure
just make it easy yeah there's that's
fine we can we can find our way down lay
our way don't tell you pickaxes is top
tier meta in this game right now unless
they have a shotgun but don't Falls
anyone else up here with us
not that I see right I got a gun too so
nice oh there is someone here that's our
team is it
it is shoot I can't see the names yeah I
saw the blue after the bag okay
who is a chest below I think hello stop
blocking me sir
uh-oh oh there's this thing right here
oh they are take that I'm blocking him
go for it oh yeah I got it we're good
good
we need shotguns oh there's a chest
right here gun tech Rin Oh got rockets
we got Rockets rockets Oh someone's dead
it's our teammate in like another room
shoot area building this is we are we
fighting building the building right now
like I'm trying to yeah I'm trying to
line up a rocket towards oh did you find
everything's fine I fell fell like that
would have been real bad I'm gonna try
to like get back to you or you're back
inside I'm inside on the side I'm just
downstairs nice there's a chest in the
one of these rooms I think it's over
this way nice grab oh they got the c-4
in here already oh yeah yeah I hear
footsteps like right outside below it
jump down I'm gonna jump down follow you
up I crashed nope just kidding 20% Oh No
follow you I don't see anything behind
us as a jump ad I feel bad because we're
not looking at the chat I know
sorry chat but this is like the worst
kind of like experience for streaming
just because like I have to look into
completely I'm looking down dude I'm all
those guys right next to me where I'm I
can't see your name it's so small
okay for the moment dead got him got him
done oh there's another guy somewhere I
don't know oh they jumped out the
building I'm gonna try to heal really
quick do it he's in front of us
oh shoot come on got him got him got him
I'm getting shot at from behind I'm down
next to you he's aren't fronting I have
no more ammo come here you get him pick
up the rocket and shoot him yeah sorry
sorry which I again which I get I like I
like that tilted that's fine you want to
get want to try this phone well we'll do
it so people can have good from oh you
want to try switching phones okay what
why not cuz people were asking about the
the six I got all right we're gonna go
to this the six here and hopefully not
get any times notifications so I'm now
switching over to a lower grade phone
which I think most people were saying
looked a lot worse or maybe not a lot
worse but it definitely looked worse
also you might want to try to look at
the we're playing it like yo yeah yeah
right yeah yeah I'm ready ready - yeah
yeah you thought you thought this is a
this is six now this is the six so those
of you with an iPhone 6 this is your
experience oh wait no I probably stopped
once I unplugged it that's what it did
okay that's fine makes sense yeah now I
have a lot less surface area to mess
around with
oh cool yours is also 21st well we know
in the streams we're on the way out how
do you stop the crash I don't know is
that it's both at least for us we have
in oh crap I didn't hit ready do we not
what did your you've got to be on your
way in because we're still in a party or
did I crash
who was crash woof okay here I'll drop
out of the game see if that works
oh you're not on my party anymore we can
fix this boom okay I got you sick did
that work
yeah okay now we're both hitting ready
yeah or wait what Phil all right so it
says wait I took the invite
oh no this this is fine this is this is
we're gonna do it accept it maybe try
inviting me okay we're join we're sugar
Network yeah okay get ready ready okay
there we go it says ready on both
screens we got this we're making it work
yeah I got like two kills that game
anonymous mink I've said this a couple
of times on different streams but the
lobby as a show format doesn't exist
anymore but we do these conversational
pieces in the office they've been pretty
good pretty cool pretty fun can check
them out they're on YouTube all right
this is it you ready you ready getting
pumped ago we go into it we gone to
Tilted it's gonna get spicy real [ __ ]
who just like just gotta go ham oh wow
we have I don't know if that's an
accurate number but there was six six
six beers oh streams go God let me see
let me see what that looks much worse
blown up to load in on the bus bus is
literally just a box is fine this is a
6s it's fine number one game in the
world we did oh my god it's whale a gear
yeah you know what it looks more
bearable on the phone compared to the
blown-up version how come we don't have
audio
that's a good question hold on hold on
guys so this is the portion of a stream
where we fly entirely by the radial
notification menu where oh that's a a
you know what yeah this this is this is
a we're going strictly by that radial
you see that the perfect simulation of
what it would be like if you're playing
on the bus
you left your headphones at home and you
don't want to just serve everyone else
got exacts radio dial cuz like you're
you're one of those people who observes
the rules like no loud music we're going
to tilted so you're you're playing with
no sound I'm playing with no sound as
the as you guys know it's fake this is
the opposite of fake my dude this is as
real as I wish I could fake this look is
my screen look like actually can I flip
it wouldn't that just do it see you see
how the screen flipped I can't believe
this
oh we're jumping we got junk we just
abandon our entire squad we missed
tilted no we're good are we going with
that AC shafting yeah today a landmark
there all right I don't know why this
boy doesn't have this is an iPhone 6
yeah yeah I'm on the iPhone 6 right now
it might be a success I thought is what
randy said I think so but I'd have to
double check do where the hell is that
building Oh No well there are a lot of
people here this is gonna be a real
spicy landing
there's aw there's weapons or something
oh let's not oh it's not me that's
someone else
oh no I'm already murdering on them oh
I'm coming oh this person's having the
best day they're gonna they had that
they had a purple SMG mark my words wait
for this to show up on ready this one's
lag here man sweet double kill in
fortnight Mobile I returning to lobby
Jakes yeah that one's no one's kind of
difficult to play on this
yeah yeah kind of like now now living
the poverty life that is the 6s I are
you ready ready
living the poverty life of this 6s with
no sound is pretty pretty fun time yeah
the no sound is definitely like no I
feel like the radio the media like what
I would assume is the media thing here
alone see how do we how do i how does
one not I'm just not gonna we're gonna
radio dial it but yeah when I was
swinging yeah it actually hitched like
here and there and I would like kind of
semi teleport yeah it's there's this is
bad I'm gonna give you a nice flip we
need to find out which that is yeah
gadge or Shiva can you tell me which
version of iPad that is because we're
gonna play on that and that's gonna be
some hotness I'm really looking forward
to them getting back to us and just
being like uh it was an old iPad that
they had found in the back of a closet
like six years ago
and no one knows anymore
I guess I could have built on that guy I
had some builds make sure the the ringer
is on I know why did you do this did
fortnight's send you codes because I
signed up they so they sent us links to
download but they did not send codes
also I'm just gonna put out there's
another PSA if someone's trying to sell
you a code don't buy it because it's not
a real thing that is nothing
please don't get got by those people
it's not worth it's a free game exactly
and I'm gonna tell you right now is this
is probably not it's not worth it's not
worth whatever you're gonna pay I'm
gonna tell you right now is the last
game I'm gonna play on the 6s yeah I
don't know which screen to look at to be
honest yeah I don't want to look at this
bigger one I'm just gonna do that your
play off of the oh my god it looks so
bad there
yeah I don't okay I'm gonna try to play
off the preview I keep looking at the
phone though all right this is
represented why can I not log into the
fortnight website a megaspore that might
be because of all the traffic going on
okay we're going to tilted yeah yeah
unless you want to try something else to
kind of get your bearings no no we
should go tells it it's going I'm gonna
jump out mm-hmm like now I'm in more two
out I'm already doing it oh my that
looks so bad oh I'm hitching this feel
like I'm playing an n64 game right now
it's pilot wings for the first half and
then when you land it's uh I need even
out here I'm not gonna make that I don't
think I'm gonna make that everything we
can I make a I'll make it I think oh me
I'll make it although I really hope no
one else is going there
oh no I'm I'm not making it I'm making
that building I wish you could got a
parachute like oh hello I didn't make it
but I'm in that building come on why do
I have a hunting rifle
oh my leg this is just like the end of
Metal Gear Solid 4 up on top of this
rooftop are you winning no there's two
people oh no that's me and my friend do
it oh you got a gun I got a gun
I can't yes we're back in this we're
alive again are we I'm having a real oh
I got see more dude throw it what do I
do with the c4 how do I get to you Ben
I'm on the roof so I'm gonna come down
to you so I count down
let's see can I put are you you are in
the building which is downright pickaxe
I'm hitting the top thing hello are you
here
hello I just opened up a oh wait did you
come down I'm on my way down
oh hello looking good my legs oh I just
warped alright so how does this how does
this see for work did you try it on that
wall over there yeah okay and then now
what I think he hit the button again
no but there's no more mm-hmm oh look at
the delay on that maybe try hitting like
tap on it to reload maybe that'll do it
I'm so scared right now this okay this
is fine this is this is the fun part no
no it definitely just throw it another
day maybe the aim button cuz it has that
hand there oh yeah yeah yeah get away
from these okay it's gone
watch watch this I do really close
before you do it
hasta la vista baby
oh no good like like a Minecraft
flashback because there's no particle in
that at all all right where we going are
we gonna go you want to go to the
streets yeah let's take it to the
streets god it lags so bad also I have
10% battery which is concerning okay
we're all gonna we're gonna run out of
battery at the same time that you miss
me that's your boy are we jumping it's
your move oh my god our buddies down
there I'm trying to jump I'm gonna save
them oh no I think I crashed no I think
I think you're no dude look look at this
I can't do anything you're in your there
you go you're back I'm not moving
oh my god literally handing my camera
did you okay this is it oh it's cuz that
explains it I'm pretty sure I crashed
bro you're disgusting you you've you've
jets out of the matrix that's me midair
about to jump down and save our path
did you win Oh No okay I'm definitely
down on the yeah Oh give me that give me
the creme de give me the you want east
of the resistance oh did I say that it's
all right I just say something for this
oh you get to play on my account though
oh we got skins yeah all right hold on
sexual fortnight oh there's two-step oh
you thought you thought that was it was
a fun time just you wait you haven't
seen anything yet I'm just gonna leave
this match and send myself a friend a
quest I have no idea oh the sounds back
that's good
add friends add
it is an iPad I don't know what it
doesn't say it's hoping I would say on
the other side oh here we can't even get
full screen resolution there is since uh
since your friend request I sent me a
friend request that work yeah you go up
to a friend request there you go
this is your offline oh no you're not
okay
did I'm gonna toss you an invite you
made it we're worried this looks so good
are you ready yeah yeah do you not
wonder how good our iPad air twos are
though yeah yo anyone out there have you
guys tested what it looks like or
finished a download on one of those ones
if anyone's finished download out there
I'd love to see what that looks like to
be very interesting
I miss Justin's higher grade iPhone
which is like oh look tutorial cool for
the first time so now now we know what
all the buttons are someone's screencap
that how does fortnight control on phone
drag to move DoubleTap to auto run what
I get that I can just run you can
DoubleTap daughter what up welcome to
the now you just grab something yeah do
you wanna do it the resolution on this
is worse than the phones I think it runs
yeah though you think so just unplug it
ah so far I like the real estate though
I'm got to be much better I got a blue
axe easier alright hit you up later for
jump buttons a little bit farther away
that's fine
see ya thank you nailed it but it was so
nice to ask Emerson Jose I think you
have an iPhone 8 plus and you're like I
want to play some for tonight in between
you know your transportation and all
that and you don't and you like have the
itch sure but if you're at home there's
no way yeah I could see you not playing
on like a console or PC like why I mean
if you want if you have kid maybe and
you want like your kid to be playing on
the the lesser platform and you're like
so I can free up the PC or something
yeah guys there's no codes so just so
you know don't get don't get got don't
get god don't buy those codes don't go
on ebay stayed stay safe yeah hold on
though you're ten bucks
we we doing that thing yeah dude I'm
lined up I'm ready for his passing salty
I'm out I'm doing it
we are iPad I'm gonna assume it's like
one of the older ones cuz it looks like
it runs better but it definitely doesn't
look as good as it does on that it's not
like the resolution yeah a C building
yeah yeah oh there's ice cream truck if
you guys die do your challenges oh shoot
hi hello there what is that stuff is
that just material we're about to find
out
that's a bandage your boy found a
handgun there's a guy here corner on me
coming coming to you now you want to run
the other way good job get got I'll
finish him off then we don't waste your
ammo take it take don't waste your ammo
got alright we gotta we gotta go yeah
it's a pretty smooth though it's just
pretty pretty good compared to the six
touch on that thing would we get it
please take that gun saw you I'm gonna
drink a little bit and then give you the
I don't know how to drop this though to
be honest
Oh backpack that's right house here you
go you read thank you huh no thank you
for letting me treat you thank you
ladies and gentleman downstairs I don't
that was me that shot or something else
what is oh I found a bunch of bricks
yeah they're people shooting outside
found some not scared me you know smiled
out here
Jeanie bandages I got some I'm good
breaking these crates down like I met Oh
actually gonna build just have one those
weird moments where you see yourself in
a game cuz like I I looked up and like
guy has the same name as me that's weird
oh wait that's me wait okay just keep
working our way down I guess open that
yeah they did I'm shooting you yeah dead
right there below below anyhow you
behind you behind you
watch out no I'm gonna I'm gonna try to
back up and not do it is he still there
yeah I think so he's running around the
side I mean he might be coming up I'm
reviving okay I'm trying to watch the
footsteps on my handy-dandy radio marker
thing he's coming up I think dirty to a
murder I hear the doors opening oh my
god it stopped resin again oh this is so
bad dude if you if you got to just like
try to try to jump that boy I'll try to
block him with my body
it's actually kind of awkward that do
some some recon here I don't see him yet
I'll tell you I'll tell you when I see
him dude it's actually weird name on
this iPad I imagine because there's a
lot of space to kind of like care Dini
bandages yes
take that he's here shot him got him got
him got him nice what's up welcome so
these are the tactics we're doing it
shotgun here yeah I've got three
shotguns in my inventory somehow it's uh
a ceased business here okay where they
at where these guys at though close the
door and some picking up that gun we're
working our way down I'm gonna pick this
up yeah you good yeah oh guy in the bush
below in a bush inside the house house
camouflage even work know
I'm gonna try to block him with my body
again oh god he's controls yeah you know
what that was my fault
I take the button now I take the blame I
could have killed that guy I okay this
is where we make him really frustrated
because he can't shoot us that's the
real victory when is kind of damn
hundred hundred though man that was
awful that's fine no you want to try
giving this a go yeah sure I'll switch
it up play on your actual characters to
see them you guys want more iPad you
guys want more iPad you want the
better-looking one or g1 I think we
should give them a better looking one
I'm in alright this is boring
whoo I'm fun to watch what I'm fun to
watch too Nate I don't get it
alright don't you guys fret we're
probably gonna wrap up here soon after
like one or two more matches yeah all
right oh you did get the thing off of
this I took it off but alright hit ready
or already done we're already in it I'm
already feeling a lot more confident
the games officially jumped the shark at
this point I you know I feel like
Mobile's the the next place that would
have to go anyway don't bring on the
batteries be dead soon yeah bro that got
its 10% warning during that last match
I figure we probably got like one in us
yeah I'm down what one one more for the
road yeah hopefully get a killer - you
want it you want to drop into a
different place or you want to keep
going up - you going to those towers
that's where the action is that is you
want a little less action than you can
now we can go somewhere else this is the
real game yes that was on iPad this is
now an iPhone 8 this is the real game
boyd tankage currently iOS players are
playing against iOS players there is no
cross-platform yet but that's supposed
to be a thing down the road yeah this is
a work in progress beta go out using the
nice phone yep I'm using the nice bone
goop how are they playing it we got a we
got the link to download it so that's
why we're putting it my fortnight's not
loading I'm not sure about that some
people are having those issues some
people are having crashes used to oh
this is mine isn't loading how do I fix
I don't know
yes weird right I think I don't think
there's buttons on that one is it yeah
oh it is everybody I just never hated so
much why would I why would I do it come
on phone just last this last game here
you signup Arctic Jack's to get it I can
tell this is a nice phone cuz I can see
the grass this is true yep yep it's a
good uh good mark of it I think this is
the size I would want to play on that
that's a good size that's a good
experience what that game is still going
are we going to tell it yeah we're going
to tilt it f it we're going out with a
bang hopefully heck yeah sign me up sign
me up a meet I'm jumping out I'm pretty
sure we might ask we must have got
whitelisted though you know what I mean
like our accounts our epic accounts or
whatever yeah well I'm not sure some
people are saying they got their invites
I guess jump fish now it sounds like a
plan looks so much better on this one
yeah it does holy crap we should just do
a quick hey guys do team out there we
literally need to record phone
comparisons oh shoot I don't know if I'm
gonna make that AC thing we can drop on
a different building you want to go to
the the right you see that square with
all the trees Oh Jude you want to be on
the open let's do it yeah I like how
you're thinking next to the bus stop I
like how our two teammates already gave
up and left damn well here we are
oh dude there's like one maybe one drop
in here hopefully that guy okay he's
running there's one guy north of us I'm
gonna try to check this building there
is a garden in here open up that door
well I found a space man on the roof did
you have a gun yes he definitely shot me
kill me space man if you can
killed someone ah
oh shoot he destroyed the floor trying
to kill me who your boy is out this is
all you I believe in you
arid traps her traps - oh it's it's the
spaceman
he got my trap doesn't have controller
support not as far as we could tell and
I think that epic actually said it's not
in yet or maybe it might not be in so
we're stuck with the touchscreen
controls for now good thing I have
double handgun right now it's a really
good tactic to use two handguns is it
fun you know admittedly even though it's
not like the optimum way to play the
game I got a lot of traps I kind of am
enjoying it like it's like a throwaway
kind of deal yeah like I could picture
myself if nothing else worked in my
house playing on it like you're a power
outage and you're just trying to play
off your yeah your phone service
something something like that yeah
they'll never see that okay so there you
go peachy keen says that the Bluetooth
controllers will be supported at a later
date they're just not in now my game
keeps crashing it's probably because the
servers are packed dang I hit the trap
too and I shot him once that's
unfortunate sorry
you think that's fine guys I think we
think we've exhausted fortnight on
mobile fourth nights on multiple devices
everything for you to enjoy don't just
die I have an Android phone but I can't
even pick that up so doing it here's
like iPhone 8 iPhone 6 was kind of Janke
iPad resident had ran fine but uh
resolution was man
we got this guy that's which prime guy
look he's just looking at a guy didn't
want to fight him like whatever anyways
thank you guys all for tuning in we'll
be back tomorrow that's two actually
yeah we'll be doing some Monster Hunter
as we kind of get ready for mr. deviljho
to show next week he's not gonna be here
tomorrow unfortunately but we'll check
out the events the you know weekly
resets stop by hunt with us hunt with us
on Monster Hunter Fridays yeah yeah but
Ben I appreciate you going through that
that time whatever that was whatever
that was and until next time until
tomorrow we'll see